JIM RADZICKI: Hello everyone
and welcome to our session,
Enabling TELUS
International to Securely
Work from Anywhere with
itopia on the Google Cloud.
I'm Jim Radzicki from
TELUS International.
I'll be joined by Jonathan
Lieberman from itopia.
This session is
really a case study
or a story of how the
impact of COVID-19
created a challenge
for TELUS International
that we were able to quickly
deploy a solution on the itopia
platform to not only take our
customers today into the cloud,
but to also create a go to
market solution for the Future
So as mentioned,
I'm Jim Radzicki,
I'm the Chief Technology
Officer for TELUS International,
and I'd like to introduce
Jonathan Lieberman from itopia.
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN: It's great
to be with you here today,
Jim, presenting
our success story
would TELUS International.
We're a Google Cloud technology
partner, premier partner,
that helps enterprises
turn every employee
into a remote worker
within 24 hours.
JIM RADZICKI: And at
TELUS International,
we're a global customer
experience digital solutions
provider.
What that means is
we design, build,
and deliver digital customer
solutions for the world's
most respected brands.
We've been doing it
for more than 15 years
and those brands include
companies such as Google.
To set the stage a little
bit for the challenge that
presented us and
particularly around COVID-19,
I want to share a little
bit about who we are
and where we operate because
that plays into the story.
So first, TELUS International.
We have nearly 50,000
employees around the globe,
we operate in over 20 countries,
we have more than 600 clients.
And we service those clients
in more than 50 languages.
In particular, we also have
a digital solutions arm.
These digital solutions
folks, again, they're
actually building and designing
digital customer experiences
for our customers.
We have just over 4,000 folks
who actually do this for us.
We operate those out
of seven countries.
And we have more than 350
clients that are particularly
focused on digital solutions.
So to set the stage, March 17.
At that moment, of those nearly
50,000 employees that we had,
TELUS International had none,
actually, of our frontline team
members who were actually in
a work from home environment.
We had some back office
folks, but really,
from a frontline perspective,
we had zero team members.
If you roll back the clock to
March 17 and think about where
we were in this
overall pandemic--
it's amazing how fast
times have changed here--
but on March 17, one
of the first countries
to decide to put a stay
at home order in place
was the Philippines.
And if you look at that
footprint that we had,
we have a large presence
at TELUS International
in the Philippines.
Fast forward a little bit in
each of the days coming up--
actually, in the next 11 days--
more than six countries
that we operated in
started to put stay put orders
and stay home orders in place,
and that trend continued.
So the challenge that
faced us was apparent.
We needed something
to quickly deploy,
that allowed us,
TELUS International,
to take this global workforce
that we had and get them up
and running in a work
and home environment.
And for that, we
reached out to Google
to look for a partner who can
help us get to that state.
JOHN TARANU: Thanks, Jim.
Hi my name is John Taranu and
I'm the Google Cloud Customer
Engineer working with
TELUS International
for the past 3 and 1/2 years.
So TELUS International
reached out to me in a panic,
just as this whole global
pandemic thing was starting up.
And I'm not a VDI
expert by any stretch,
so I didn't know what
to recommend initially.
So I reached out
to people who are
VDI experts within
our cloud team,
and I asked them for
their suggestions,
and they recommended
that I consider itopia.
Now itopia was a Google
Cloud Partner of the Year,
and they had this
fantastic reputation
of spinning up virtual desktop
solutions rapidly and securely.
I also reached out to some
of my peer customer engineers
who had worked
with itopia before,
and they had only
great things to say
about how responsive
and collaborative
the itopia team was
with their customers.
So I felt really excited
that we had an opportunity
to help TELUS International
with this urgent crisis,
and I went out and reached
out to the itopia team.
And that was a sort of a
great collaboration together.
So over to you, Jonathan.
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN:
Thanks, John.
So I'm sitting at my desk
and up pops this email
from TELUS International.
This is the actual
email from someone
with a great sense of
humor asking rhetorically,
if you could launch VDI over the
weekend, that would be great.
And it turns out
they weren't kidding.
TELUS International
literally needed
to provide thousands
of workers access
to their mission critical
business applications
in desktops over
the coming weekend.
Now an email with
this kind of request
might have struck fear
with other companies,
but for us, it was just
another day at the office.
We were not at all
fazed by this request
and our teams were
ready to get to work.
At the most basic level,
itopia turns every employee
into a remote worker.
We do this through a
solution we call Desktop
as a Service, which
gives employees
fast and secure access
to their desktops
and apps as though they were
physically in the office.
Now here's Jamie,
who works in one
of TELUS's international
large delivery centers
in the Philippines who
is now working from home.
Using an e-device, a Chromebook,
MacBook, laptop, PC, or tablet,
Jamie is able to connect through
a web browser or a small app
to a full cloud-hosted
desktop or just the apps
that she uses most.
Instead of the desktop or the
application being installed
on a server under her desk,
it's being hosted in the nearest
Google Cloud data center,
where the connections are fast,
the security is tight, and the
technology is unparalleled.
So we built itopia to
simplify and modernize
Virtual Desktop
Infrastructure or VDI,
as most people commonly
refer to it today.
VDI is a technology that's
been around since the mid-'90s.
It was invented way before
hyperscale cloud computing
to help companies enable
their people to work remotely.
Unfortunately, VDI got very
complex and costly to install
and maintain.
It consists of multiple stacks
of hardware and software
from compute to
storage to networking,
and this requires a lot
of upfront investment
into a bunch of
gear and software
that sits in the data
center, and begins
to depreciate in value the
minute that you buy it.
And to make matters worse,
it cannot scale on demand
to handle a situation
like we had with COVID-19,
and it must be managed by
a team of senior engineers,
So what we did at
itopia was completely
rethink the approach to
VDI by modernizing it
as a fast to deploy,
simple to use, Cloud
native solution purpose
built for Google Cloud.
We got rid of the
complex technology stack
and replaced it with
a unified console that
can be easily operated by tier 1
tech, who can enable and manage
a worldwide VDI deployment
in any Google data center
with a single click.
JIM RADZICKI: Thanks, Jon.
So here we were, a
pandemic facing the world.
Through Google and
the relationship,
we were introduced
to itopia, who
showed us and were
impressed with an incredibly
quick to deploy.
If you think about the times
we're talking about here,
this sounds like
something you would
have done over the
course of weeks or months
with an introduction,
getting the proof of concept.
We were up and running
on the proof of concept
within the first 24
hours, proving and testing
the technology to make
sure it could work.
Soon after proving that
it was available to us,
now we needed to get
into securing it.
So we had to look
at the architecture.
We had to make sure that for our
client base, for our employees,
not only could we
keep them safe,
but we can keep our customers
and their data safe.
We needed to understand
the architecture
and how that architecture
is flexible enough
for us to secure the wide
varieties of customers
that we had.
So with that, Jon, I flipped it
back over to you to say, hey,
how can we secure it?
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN: Thanks, Jim.
So the novel aspect about
our approach to VDI,
and the reason that we're
able to deploy it so quickly
is because our solution is pure
automation and orchestration.
There's no software to
install, no hardware
to buy, procure, and implement.
We're automating
what Google already
has in place and everything
runs in our customer's projects.
We consider five key
elements to what we automate
in our modern DAS deployment.
Number one is the RDS
infrastructure platform itself
in every single
region that's required
and in the case of
TELUS International,
seven regions around the world.
Number two is the
networking which
consist of firewalls,
VPNs, and load balancers--
again, everything that
Google brings to the table
from a technology point of view.
The third is file servers, which
are used for storage and data
protection.
Fourth is the directory services
that leverage Google-managed AD
or allows a customer to spin up
their own domain controllers.
It's a very flexible approach.
And then finally, a
management and monitoring
console, which
leverages Stackdriver
and Google BigQuery.
JIM RADZICKI: Thanks, Jon.
Now we're checking the
boxes for what we had.
So March 17, we're
stuck, we needed
something quick to deploy.
We now have a solution
that we can deploy.
Now we needed to make it secure.
We needed to make sure that
we can actually keep employees
safe and customers safe.
Well, as you saw in the
opening, TELUS International,
we have more than 600 clients.
There is no one solution,
no one setting that's
going to apply to all 600.
We needed this to
be customizable.
We needed it to be refinable.
We needed to know that
we can use it for voice.
We need to know
data-heavy applications.
Some of our clients require
us to use their own VPN.
Some of them didn't want
the desktop to be shown.
Some of them only wanted certain
tool sets to be available.
Some of them had
requirements for HIPAA.
requirements-- you name it.
With 600, there were
600 different ways
in which we had this.
For that, I reached
back out to Jon
again to understand how we
can customize and refine
the itopia desktop.
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN:
That's right, Jim.
So in order to meet TELUS
International's requirements,
our software enabled the
security policies, rules,
permissions from TELUS
International's clients on prem
ADs to be extended
into Google Cloud.
And every situation, as you
can imagine, was different.
And our solution
acts as a bridge
so that there's no compromise
in security profile
when one of TELUS
International's clients
are being transitioned and
delivered through the cloud.
Now every client
needed to enable
support for a variety of use
cases from light workloads
to productivity apps to
heavier graphical and media
applications.
And our platform
made it possible
with easy-to-add custom
images to provision workers,
auto scaling of virtual
machines, intelligent user
routing to the nearest
GCP data center.
And this ensured low latency and
delivered a very unified point
and click console
in every browser.
And because our software
is orchestration-only,
we don't have any access
to the customer's data.
This means that from a
regulatory point of view,
our software and the solution
that we deliver through Google
was able to adhere
to the standards
that TELUS International's
clients demanded,
from SOC to PCI to FINRA,
HIPAA, FedRAMP, you name it.
Jim, back over to you.
JIM RADZICKI: Thanks, Jon.
So we're checking the boxes
now on all the things,
and again, thinking back, this
was literally days into this.
It seems, again, like this
would be the things we
do over the course of months.
So we were quick to deploy.
We got that proof of
concept up and running.
Able to show that we can
get the desktops deployed,
that they were easy to maintain.
We had to secure them.
We had to prove to our
clients and our employees
that we're able to make
it a safe and productive
environment, keeping
their data as safe
as it would be as if
it were in the office.
Then we needed to customize it.
We had to make it
more refinable.
Every client has
their requirement
that needed to be in place,
and we needed to get it done,
and we check that off, as well.
Lastly, operating around
the globe as we do,
operating with as
many folks as we do,
we needed to make sure this
solution was globally scalable.
Extremely important in a
virtual desktop environment,
low latency.
The distance between or
the time between where
the servers are to
where the end points are
people working from home--
the smaller the better.
It just works better that way.
So for that, we reached
back out to Google
to learn a little bit about how
we can deploy this on the GCP.
JOHN TARANU: So one
of the biggest reasons
the TELUS International
team were considering
Google Cloud for the solution
is our global footprint,
with over two dozen
regions around the world
and new regions that are
coming online and regularly.
This is especially important
to TELUS International
as their employee base is
spread out around the world.
The sites in North
and Central America,
many countries in eastern
and western Europe, India,
and the Philippines.
So we designed a
deployment of itopia
for TELUS International in
six Google Cloud regions, such
that for every TELUS
International geography,
they had at least
two TCP regions
within the same continent
for additional redundancy.
And the magic that brings
together TELUS International's
employees to their virtual
desktop environments
is one of Google Cloud's
greatest strengths--
a private, secure, high
speed, global backbone.
That's the same backbone
that already provides
them access to Google
services that they rely on
in their daily lives.
And this ensures that TELUS
International employees working
from home around the world have
a connection through their home
internet service provider,
through the existing
in-country high speed peer
connections that Google
has maintained for decades
with telcos around the world,
directly into Google's
backbone, and then
to their virtual
desktop at Google Cloud.
And for each site, there
were redundant network paths
to take to the servers.
Especially for employees
in places like Guatemala
and the Philippines who
rely on submarine cables
to connect to the internet,
having a redundant network path
to a server on the same
continent instead of undersea
cables across the ocean means
that their latency is lower
and their user experience on
their virtual desktop is good.
And if TELUS International
tried to build
their own private
network appearing
to serve their work from
home employees like this,
it would be
prohibitively expensive.
By relying on Google Cloud,
a global deployment is easy.
JIM RADZICKI: So
there's no better scale
than running this on the
Google Cloud Platform.
So now we've checked
all the boxes.
We had it up and running, we
made it serviceable and secure,
we've refined it for
our customer needs,
we've leveraged the GCP to
scale this around the globe.
And literally, within
just a few days,
we have stable operations.
So where do we go from here?
Well, as I mentioned
also, TELUS International,
with our digital
solutions capabilities,
we actually were able to
take this to the market.
So in a true sense
of partnership,
not only were we leveraging
this for our own needs,
but we also decided that our
success story is something
that a lot of other
people are going to need,
not only in the
current pandemic,
but as you look into
the future, as well.
So one more time, I reached
back out to Jon to say,
hey, how can we take
advantage of this in a go
to market strategy.
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN: Thanks, Jim.
The natural next
question is this
since we've gotten it deployed
and successfully onboarded
thousands of
workers, what can we
do next to make our
partnership even stronger?
And we talked to
your solutions folks
who were so impressed with
the speed and simplicity
of our platform that
we together decided
to integrate it and
bring it to market
as part of your core customer
care suite of solutions.
JIM RADZICKI: Yes, it's
become actually a part
of our overall package now,
what we call Work From Anywhere.
So if you think
about what's required
for someone to work from home--
and this is the true
future road of operations
that we're working toward--
first, you need to connect.
So as you look at TELUS
International's work
from anywhere
solution, the first
is a cloud native
omnichannel-centered platform
that allows folks
to connect with not
only their own companies,
but also with their customers
anywhere and in an internet
connection can reach.
Right smack in the
middle of the platform
is exactly what we just
talked about from itopia--
to enable that remote
virtual desktop
so that we can bring not only
the omnichannel solution,
but the full suite of
desktop applications
that were needed with inside
your company or your site--
bring those to the home in
a secure and safe manner.
And then lastly, you need
to engage with people.
We talk about all of the
technology through this,
but it's still at
the end of the day,
people who are
working and connecting
with their customers.
So a full suite of products for
the customer experience that
allow us to stay meaningfully
engaged with our employees
while they're working from home.
So to give you a
little sense of it,
here's a snapshot of
actually, those employees
all working from their
at-home environments
with virtual desktops.
And it wouldn't
be complete if we
didn't show a little bit with
all of us having our pets
there, as well.
So a little bit of that
positive experience
from the work at home
and some of the pets
at TELUS International.
So with that, I thank
you for joining us.
I'm Jim Radzicki.
You can reach out to me
here at jimradzicki@telu
sinternational.com.
And I'll hand it to
Jonathan Lieberman
to say a few words
to close us out.
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN: Thanks, Jim.
So in our view, this
is only the beginning
of a very exciting partnership.
To take our joint
solution to the market,
to help companies
all over the world,
to give their employees the
ability to work from home.
Thanks again for joining us
and for having us and allowing
us to tell our success story.